[Music]
is
Spartan
lock I have spent enough years with Oni
to know the
truth once this is
over after all I have
done they'll order
you to kill us
both
fire team Osiris over the last 72 hours
five colonies have experienced identical
events massive destruction Forerunner in
origin and Dr Katherine Elizabeth Hy has
managed to contact us she claims to have
information on these
attacks Hy is currently in Covenant
custody on the surface of kamada your
mission is to insert Behind Enemy Lines
retrieve Hy and bring her back to
Infinity be advised Dr Hy is accompanied
by Covenant supreme leader julm dama if
you have the opportunity understood
Commander good luck Spartan lock
Infinity out cracking gear online
affirmative say before we make this jump
anybody want to say a few words I figure
God can hear how scared I am so can
everyone
else lock you buying first drink when
we're done you ask you
buy fire team Osiris the light is
green
[Music]
com
check
com for confine L copy that Kaka Spartan
Buck online and ready Spartan Veil
Online weapons
free
contact
the
head
[Music]
out no
a
incoming we could have taken him let's
move Veil keep an here on CS affirmative
denaka pull Security on it
all Hy and AMA are H up inside a 4Runner
structure ahead that's our Target so so
Hy called us she said there was
something big happening and gave Captain
lasy coordinates to find her it must be
something big one hell of a
trap
contact
must
continue take fire from the
L all clear move on toward H's
[Music]
position
4Runner Soldier up the cliffs get after
them soldiers just teleported through
that ice
wall
promethium all sides we could push right
up the middle that would be rough might
want to consider flanking them move
smart fire with a purpose is firing on
me is
SM fire from the left
[Music]
Char way don't hide for
me
[Music]
I'm down need an
assist you
go thanks
Spartan C down
I'm
grounded targeting a soldier a banana
block I'm up thanks hostile spotted on
the
way down part of
me the
human need
assistance thanks Spartan on your
knes I
fail need
help no worries lo I got you I'm up
thanks I'm
down need
assistance block enemy firing from that
system
Jam
[Music]
appreciate the
hand good one
Target
in got hit soldiers up
[Music]
there
moving
[Music]
lach fire from that
barricade i r fire on the to system
failed system down down I'm down up
thanks
spart are is clear move
on good work
everyone